bon
[Musique]
paradis de l'eau douce au pays des mines
et des forêts les habitants ici disent
vivre d'amour et d'eau pure richesse
inestimable qui berce leurs paysages et
qui a fait le succès de l'entreprise et
ce cas
[Musique]
luda mode est l'un des meilleurs au
monde c'est plus que de la fierté c'est
c'est plus qu'un sentiment
d'appartenance et je pense d'un orgueil
un certain point pour les gens de la
région
si c'est tout qui a fait de ce jeune
juriste un véritable activiste la
crainte de voir une compagnie étrangère
mettre en péril le fleuron de la région
j'ai jamais vu une telle mobilisation à
hanoi quand on sait que la population
est aussi fière de la qualité de l'eau
mais il n'y a pas de risque à prendre
dans l'opinion publique la gueule
pour comprendre cet attachement à l'eau
il faut comprendre l'escarcelle mathieu
berry c'est un peu lépine dorsale de la
région dépôt de 135 kilomètres de long
où le sable et le gravier laissée par le
retrait des glaciers agit comme un
filtre et purifient l'eau on peut dire
qu'on est un peu dans le coeur de lescar
l'hydrogéologue vincent cloutier et u17
esquerre depuis des années on peut
définir le vestiaire comme étant
rémunéré pour une contamination à partir
de la surface quand la neige voit au
fond ce printemps l'eau va s'infiltrer
et voici coulé entre les grains de sable
et gravier c'est ici que l'eau est
puisée puis redistribués aux citoyens
dames aussi joyeux ont minutieusement
protégé par les au maire sébastien
d'astous alors voici le plu de la ville
d'amos et préfère la qualité de notre
eau
c'est luca directement
zakopalova elle est acheminée
directement chez les citoyens n'est pas
traitement pas de chloration aux côtes
lors le risque
le voici trop s'en fait à celle ouvert
qui va avoir du camionnage à chaque jour
le projet d'une mine de lithium à ciel
ouvert à 500 mètres de cette esquerre si
précieux et surtout un complexe minier
de la taille de soixante dix huit
terrains de football qui s'en approche
encore plus les hydrogéologues de la
compagnie à kehl on a pu poser des
questions nous ont indiqué qu'il y avait
des possibilités de deux d'impact sur le
sur lescar en fait par le projet denis
alors au lieu de 10 nuls et inquiétudes
ça les eaux raviver le promoteur du
projet est engagé dans une véritable
course contre la montre téléphone
intelligent voitures électriques
les nouvelles technologies carbure aux
batteries de lithium un véritable or
blanc un marché en pleine expansion
or pour espérer s'imposer rapidement sa
yona à structurer son projet de mine
pour s'éviter de longues consultations
et audiences publiques environnementales
c'est là que le bât blesse les crânes
qu'on a puis-je les centres sont très
présents dans la population c'est en
fait que lescar soit menacée car un seul
risque en fait de d'atteinte à
l'intégrité de lescar à sa qualité
[Musique]
malgré tout les analyses toutes les
études réalisées au cours des dernières
années
vincent cloutier peine à prédire les
risques que posera la mine de lithium
toute activité de industriels sur ou à
proximité d'un esquerre va soulever des
précipations actuellement on n'a pas
l'ensemble des connaissances sont pour
évaluer le risque potentiel sur la
ressource en eau de l'escale
la courbe de screens secondes ces
craintes le promoteur les a bien entendu
il promet que les études menées par six
consultants vont démontrer que la mine
ne pose aucun risque je peux vous dire
une chose et on voit même en faire un
engagement formel au niveau de la
direction de soyaux n'a québec c'est que
jamais nous n'allons toucher ni à
l'intégrité ni à la qualité de l'eau de
leicester dans une région qui vit de
l'exploitation minière tous les acteurs
politiques sont bien plus dans la mine
contre leicester s'il dilemme entre
développement économique et protection
de l'environnement
et vous savez pas trop inquiet par une
question soulevée par sept mille neuf
banques en fait c'est pas une question
d'inquiétude ce que présentement on est
en contrôle
la préfaisabilité de la mène et fait ils
vont aller en faisabilité on suit le
dossier moi je suis un chouchou en
rapport direct avec les gestionnaires de
cerneaux mining et d autres projets
munich pourrait éclore pour rodrigue
turgeon il est bien là le problème
est ce qu'on peut vraiment s'attendre ce
qu'une compagnie multinationale qui
vient ici je tenir ses activités en
portant ses propres intérêts vont tout
faire en sorte qu'il y aura pas
d'atteinte à l'environnement pour les
générations à venir au delà de sa
profession de foi la minière saiosn à
est confiante de dissiper les doutes de
la population processus en place et très
rigoureux
alors les experts encore une fois du
ministère des ressources naturelles les
experts
du ministère de l'environnement vont
analyser ses études et ce sont eux qui
vont décider si les études qui ont été
réalisées qui sont conformes à ce que de
meilleurs au niveau de la science
actuelle qu'est-ce que ça prendrait pour
vous rassurer
ce qu'on veut c'est que l'état prenne en
charge le dossier de manière à s'assurer
qu'on ait des études indépendantes
rodrigues turgeon a peut-être lancer sa
campagne pour protéger les scraire
contre la mine de lithium
mais finalement c'est tout le système
d'approbation des mines au québec que
son mouvement tenter ici de remettre en
question
ouais manuel la mise l'environnement à
d'ailleurs été interpellé à plusieurs
reprises là-dessus est-ce que le
gouvernement va finir par intervenir
écoutez en ce moment où au cabinet de la
ministre du développement durable
isabelle melançon se dit très sensible
aux préoccupations des citoyens et on
affirme même le site qu'on veut utiliser
tous les moyens nécessaires pour assurer
la protection de cette richesse
régionale alors le signal clair qui est
envoyé en même temps on dit au cabinet
de la ministre
il est trop tôt pour trancher parce que
les études de la minière ont pas encore
été formellement déposée auprès du
ministère ce que les gens les opposants
comme rodrigue surgeons réclame c'est
que la ministre utilise son pouvoir pour
imposer des audiences publiques sur
l'environnement
parce que ça permettrait une étude
beaucoup plus approfondie du projet et
dans certains cas ça peut forcer les
minières a dévoilé certains documents
prendre des engagements publics donc
éclairé des ondes d'ombré qui subsistent
dans le dossier ouaip et l'heure des
choix va arriver assez rapidement
d'ailleurs le oui parce que c'est le 18
mai prochain que la minière saiosn à
québec va finalement dévoilé ses études
s'en suivra deux semaines de
consultation publique menée par la
compagnie minière
alors c'est certain qu'à partir de ce
moment là la pression va monter auprès
du ministère de l'environnement
mais je peux vous prédire si linke si
ledit bonne s'arrêtera pas là non plus
parce que vous voyez ces gens laissent
qu'ils réclament c'est que québec change
les règles du jeu il qu'on cesse de s'en
remettre aux consultants et aux experts
des compagnies minières pour évaluer les
projets et que ce soit vraiment le
gouvernement du québec qui fasse selon
lui même dans l'espoir bien sûr qu'on
veut mieux protéger le bien public
il a dans ce cas là c'est un joyau
vraiment haut et de la région dans la
région donc merci emmanuel très bien
revoir